sur la base de ce texte constitutionnel
et bien nos maires pourront malgré
encore une fois l'interdiction que veut
promulguer monsieur bayrou h dans le
hall et bien voilà c'est merci aux
valeurs dans les mairies des trucs à la
renaissance religieux c'est la laïcité
jour sur notre tradition monsieur
mélenchon je sais vous déranger ces
mêmes quelle 12e d'où vous tenez je ne
serais je suis pas chercher mes livres
agences des salaires monde avec qu'est
ce que c'est qu'un président exemplaire
c'est d'abord un président qui dit la
vérité aux français sur la réalité de la
france et la réalité du monde
un président exemplaire c'est un
président qui met en oeuvre les
engagements qu'il a pris devant le
peuple
quelles que soient les difficultés un
président exemplaire c'est un président
qui respecte son premier ministre qui
respecte le gouvernement et qui respecte
l'équilibré des pouvoirs prévus par la
constitution fillon voilà il est en face
de moi que des histoires et plo fouille
plus plus on sent la corruption puis on
sent la triche et à côté de ça donc en
plus et des bonhommes qui nous explique
qu'il faut la rigueur qu'il faut
l'austérité et eux-mêmes hippique dans
les caisses publiques donc il ya comme
ça oui dans nature merci donc bon c'est
ce que j'ai dit je les dis ensuite est
aussi le pen à côté alors va peut-être
réagir aussi mais le pen pareil on pique
dans les caisses publiques car là c'est
pas c'est pas ici c'est l'europe à
l'europe pour quelqu'un qui est anti
européen ça ce ne serait même pas de
piquer de l'argent de l'europe
et le pire c'est qu'en plus le fn qui se
dit antisystème le s'emmerde pas du tout
se protègent grâce aux lois du système
grâce à l'immunité parlementaire et donc
nous refuse d'aller au convocation
policière donc peinard donc là tout ça
ça illustre ce coup là c'est pour la
police ça ça illustre mais quand nous
les convoqués par la police mais vous
voyez par exemple on a pas d'immunité
ouvrière désolé on y va ce que vous
proposez
c'est la guerre économique et nous ne
sommes ni la suisse ni la corée du sud
madame le pen la réalité de notre vie
économique c'est que ce seront des
destructions d'emplois ce que vous
proposez c'est le gatinois nationalisme
moi je viens d'une région où les
conflits entre justement les pays
d'europe qui est jean lassalle la très
bien rappelé faut savoir d'où
viens et où cette séparation nous
ramènera le nationalisme c'est la guerre
je veux bien que tout le monde ait un
schéma en tête disant je vais montrer
les muscles et puis si ça bouge pas on
sortira peut-être mais que se passe-t-il
derrière parce que plan a plan b c'est
très intéressant mais c'est quoi le plan
ces autres cas le plan pour les français
derrière en matière d'inflation en
matière d'emploi en matière de dette moi
en tout cas je préfère avoir aujourd'hui
la remise en cause de l'austérité parce
qu'elle est en train de disloquer
l'europe mais construire l'europe et
continuer à parier sur les la
coopération parce que demain pas
d'europe c'est la compétition à tout va
la compétition va tout va et ça je n'ai
pas entendu ça